dans les contrées située au nord
jusqu'aux reins ou jusqu'au port
d'anvers ce sont des centaines de
collines et de pleine charge et de
richesses andré dhôtel le disait dans
son roman il n'existe pas une forêt mais
mille fort est le pays où on n'arrive
jamais un chef-d'oeuvre merveilleux de
1955 à re découvrir au théâtre
moi j'avais découvert ce livre
collégiens et en fait qui m'a jamais
trop quitter il m'a accompagné il m'a
fait découvrir l'oeuvre immense d'andré
dhôtel j'ai mis des années en fait avant
de me décider à tenter l'adaptation du
pays où on n'arrive jamais qui est pas
simple parce que en fait c'est un roman
initiatique c'est un roman d'itinérance
on passe d'un lieu à un autre quelque
chose qui en fait anti théâtrale quoi
qu'il défie les lois du théâtre en
création depuis un an la pièce est jouée
pour la première fois l'histoire reprend
celle de gaspard le jeune garçon se lie
d'amitié avec un enfant fugitif à la
recherche de son pays
un récit enchanteur qui rend au monde
toute sa poésie
aujourd'hui j'ai vu un éclair qui
traçait l'arc en ciel
pour moi ça a été un message de vie qui
dit à l'homme regardait la nature
regarder les forêts regarder les arbres
respecter les plantes respecter les
champignons y a pas besoin de faire des
milliers de kilomètres pour voyager
voyager autour de votre maison
intéressez vous à ce qui se passe
écoutez l'elysée peut regarder quelque
chose qui a changé moi qui a changé en
fait ma vision de la littérature de la
ville une de là
naples n'a plus jamais jamais jamais
quitté quoi un voyage fantastique qui
parlera aux petits comme aux grands
enfants par un jeu de toiles peintes et
de vidéos la compagnie in cauda les
emmènera jusqu'au bout du monde